I was mentioning this one possibility
that we are living on a
three-dimensional surface but that there
are other dimensions out there and in
string theory you would need ten
dimensions and it's possible there's a
number different possibilities one is
that and at every point in this room
there's a tiny curled up dimension that
we don't know about because nothing that
we that we can't go in there it's too
tiny and nothing we know about can fit
in there either maybe gravity can
communicate through these additional
curled-up dimensions that's one
possibility the other possibility is
that the other one of the other
dimensions or more of them could be
large and cut off at the other end by
another kind of another brain similar to
ours so people wonder well what is the
effect of the of the matter is there
some kind of dark matter on that other
brain and that's actually what we're
seeing when we look at galaxies or is
there when when the accelerator at CERN
the LHC when they're taking data are
they going to see missing energy that
leaks out into the extra dimensions this
again would require saw the exact extra
dimensions to be somewhat larger in
order for that to happen but it is
certainly possible oh another project
that I worked on this one was a lot of
fun if we're living on this on a
three-dimensional surface like that and
it's possible for some gravitational
signal or I don't know what kind of
signals something to leave our brain go
into the extra dimensions and then come
back in the in the distant future and if
the shapes are right so imagine imagine
our brain is curved and the extra
dimension so I guess I'll try to
illustrate this so our brain is like
this and in the extra dimensions you can
cut it off bye-bye you can do a shortcut
path by cutting across then you could
communicate information in a way that
looks like it's faster than the speed of
light so that would be fun
it is a spatial I am thinking in terms
of spatial extra dimensions so not time
there are some models where you have
additional time dimensions but what I'm
talking about now you still have the
single time dimension but the so and we
have here you know the you move to the
right you move up you move the three
dimensions that we're used to and
probably you could just keep going on
infinitely in any of those directions
whereas the other dimensions I'm talking
about like I said they're if they're
small then so where I'm sitting right
now I could move in the X direction I
could move forward I could move in the Y
direction I could move to the right I
could move in the Z direction I could
move up but I cannot move in this other
direction because I'm too big so these
other directions are there like curled
up little circles and they're just
really tiny that's that's one in one
possibility